(upbeat music)
- Welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour,
I'm actually really loving the topic
that we're gonna be talking about today,
self-care, vulnerability and
real talk with Tara Schuster.
And I think this is a topic
that's really salient and
important for all of us.
I know definitely for me with everything
that I have going on with the challenges
that come on a daily basis.
I think for all of us as a society,
this is just something
that's really important
and relevant to all of us.
So I'm honored to be able to welcome Tara
on the program today.
For any who don't know her,
I'm gonna give you just a
little bit of an introduction.
Tara is a bestselling
author and playwright.
She's also an accomplished
and season entertainment executive.
She served as the vice president
of Talent and Development
in Comedy Central,
where she was the executive
in charge of two Emmy winning shows,
key and Peele and @midnight.
In 2020, she also released a book,
Buy Yourself the Effing Lilies,
which debuted at number one
in humor essays and self-help
on (indistinct) and Kendall
and was also considered by many magazines
as one of the best new books in 2020.
So again, I'm deeply honored
to be able to welcome Tara
Schuster to the program today.
Thanks so much for being here.
- Thanks for having me Dr. Addy,
I'm thrilled to have this
conversation with you.
- Well, definitely looking forward to it
and just knowing your work
and the conversations that
you've had over the years,
your book, your upcoming book as well,
I think this is just gonna
be a great conversation
and topic, a lot of our listeners
will really be able to
engage with as well.
So as you know, as our listeners know,
I always like to start with a check-in.
So just wanted to start there
and just see how you're doing these days
in the midst of everything
that we're all dealing with as a society.
And just the things that
even walking through
in your personal life as well.
- Yeah, it's a lot of ups
and downs, I can't lie.
And I would honestly question anybody
who's not feeling some
amount of ups and downs
and you know my hope in my own growth
is to find equanimity at some point
but I don't got that at this exact moment.
So that said, I'm finding
myself better and better
able not to be trapped
in my own thought loops
and stories and anxieties.
And by becoming better at accepting them,
accepting that they are
just what is happening
and that that's not bad.
It doesn't make me bad.
It doesn't make all my
healing all for not,
like it's not some
catastrophe it just kinda is,
the more and more I get
comfortable with that
the easier and easier it
is to loosen the grip.
And then all of a sudden,
I'm not in some like anxiety spiral.
So I'd say ups and downs
but overall actually a lot more resilient
to the different moods
my brain and emotions
can fling me into and so yeah, mixed bag.
- And I appreciate that honesty.
And I think it's interesting
that you put those two together too.
'Cause you talk about
the honesty of accepting
that they're there
but then also still
trying to build resilience
at the same time.
So it's not like you're just accepting
and saying, oh, well
that's just the way it is
and there's nothing that
can be done about it.
- What I find is,
if I don't accept it, if I
resist it then I really suffer.
Then it has a texture of something like
really that's pulling me under.
But when I just say, oh, it is what it is
and that's not my entire life,
that's just this one little slice
that has become a richer and
richer way to just calm down.
Because the circumstances
outside are crazy
like even though the pandemic
seems to be in a better place
than it was, like what
does that even mean?
A better place in a global pandemic
of death and destruction?
Like this is kind of
a worst case scenario.
So I'm just trying to be a
little, cut myself a little slack
for the fact that I'm
not a hundred percent
every single day.
- Yeah, that seems so
healthy in a lot of ways,
I mean, you put it in a
great perspective too.
I mean, the pandemic is
still going on, it's better
but it's not as if we're
completely (indistinct),
so there's still--
- Yeah, like it's good
for a global pandemic.
Like that's not a real phrase.
Like one we would you have
ever said that before,
like, oh, I'm doing good for
being in a global pandemic.
Like that's crazy.
- Yeah, but yet at the same time
where I know I'm talking like that,
a lot of us were just
all talking that way.
So it's just kind of the
reality for the moment too.
And I think you know within the pandemic
even this idea that you've
talked about the acceptance,
it seems like there's
a lot more acceptance
of how anxiety provoking this
has been across the board.
I mean, other situations I've said
in some ways we've almost
gone through a global trauma
just in terms of not knowing
exactly how things would play out
and all the anxiety that comes with that.
So I think for a lot of people
who may not have been able to relate
as well to anxiety beforehand,
this became somewhat of an equalizer,
I mean, that's total understanding
because it also heightened
some of the disparities
were already there by the sense that
globally we're kind of dealing
with this uncertainty and anxiety,
I think that's been huge
for us as a society.
But even with the idea of acceptance,
why do you think even
though maybe it's easier
for people to accept now,
why do you think it's just
so difficult for us to accept
when things are actually challenging?
I mean, it seems like it's taboo,
we can't talk about it,
we pretend that it's fine.
Like we're, what's going on there?
- It's a funny thing and it's
something I'm writing about
you know like when you're
in line at a grocery store
and there's like a woman behind you
and she's in tears, completely upset
and you're like, "Are you okay?"
And she's like, "I'm fine."
And you're like, "I'm pretty
sure you're not fine."
And like, it's pretty weird
that our gut reaction
just deny, deny, deny,
I'm fine, distance from this.
And I think there are a
couple of things going on,
I think on the societal level,
and particularly in America,
we have this, the individual,
the lone individual, who's
like gonna do it on their own.
And when we sell ourselves that myth
and we're supposed to be so
strong and never ask for help.
And then my book is half
memoir, half self-help.
And I remember when I was
talking to the marketing people
and they told me,
well, it's gonna be in
the self-help category.
I was like, euh, I don't
wanna be a self-help writer.
Like that's so cheesy and
gross and terrible and lame.
And I really had to check myself,
why is it bad to help yourself?
Like the people who have the power
to pick up a self-help
book should be lauded.
Like those are the powerful strong people
who are taking a step back and saying,
"I have an issue and I'm
strong enough to deal with it."
So I think we're fed a
bunch of lies about our,
how we need to do things
alone, I think that's one part.
And the other part I think is,
we use terms like I'm fine,
I'm okay, when we're genuinely not
so that we can distance
ourselves from what's real.
Like it's I think the defense
mechanism a lot of the time
to reject the reality,
reject the pain, I'm fine.
Moving on, I don't wanna talk about it.
And it also gives everyone
in our lives cover
because then they don't
have to be intimate
with our problems either.
And then they don't have
to face their own issues
that are issues might kick up.
And it just puts us all
in a terrible position
because then everybody's
lying, like nothing is true.
And people feel like they can't
reach out and ask for help
because they don't think
anybody else is experiencing
what they're experiencing
because what we're fed is that
we should all just be fine.
So that's sort of my take on
why we default to I'm fine.
Which also by the way, is so lame.
Like I don't wanna live my
life as fine, it's so sad.
Like wanna feel something.
- And that's so important.
I think like you said, it
leaves a stigma in place too.
Some of our earlier episodes
we were talking with a NFL player
and he was saying some of
the same types of things
in terms of nobody wanna talk about it,
everybody going through it themselves.
But once you get everyone in the room
actually talking about it
and they're all like realizing
that they're all dealing
with the same thing,
they thought they were the only one.
Then (indistinct) this
collective group theory
therapy type of moment
where people can actually
walk through things together
and actually learn from each other.
So I taught so and so forth.
- Yeah, totally.
And I think we're kind
of in a societal group
therapy moment, you know that
there's great disparities
about what kinds of suffering
and what disadvantages people have.
And there's a lot packed within that
but if you are a human on
planet earth currently,
our current circumstances are not ideal.
So to add to some extent
everybody is kind of being
confronted with this.
And I think even having publicly athletes,
like the football player you mentioned
or you know this week the tennis player
in a French Open dropping out
for her own mental health,
like having examples
of people saying like,
hey wait, my mental health is my priority
without that there's nothing else.
I mean, this wouldn't have
happened two years ago,
you know, people were not this open.
So I think it might be an
unintended good consequence
of the pandemic is just,
it ripped off so much of the artifice
and so much of the like,
everything is fine.
We jus patchworked over this whole thing
and doesn't it look nice?
And it's like, no, it doesn't,
the insights are rotten.
- Exactly, yeah, and I
noticed even the timing
of your book released too.
I'm sure you weren't predicting that
and potentially planning to release a book
during the pandemic
but how do you think that
affected like how it was received?
Do you think there was a tie in there?
- I 100%, I mean, obviously
you work so hard on a book,
you know in some ways that
book took me 30 years to write,
it took three dedicated years
but 30 of thinking about the book.
And I was supposed to go
on like a big book tour
and bought a dress to wear.
And like that dress is
still sitting in my closet,
a year and a half later,
like who knows when I'm
gonna wear that dress.
So that was different.
That was an adjustment
and that had its own
amount of grief for me
because it wasn't how I
pictured things going.
And it wasn't what I expected.
And the book coming out in the pandemic
was the perfect time
for this exact message
because people desperately needed some,
with so much structure
taken out of their lives.
It was actually the
perfect time to build in
some good habits and
everything in my book,
you know my book is about self-care
and how to bring small
rituals into your life
that hope you enjoy your
life and be present for it.
People had time to try these
things, if for example,
if you weren't commuting
to the office anymore
that meant you had 20 minutes to journal.
And because everything in my
book is free or super low cost
there were also just no
barriers to entry there.
And it helped that the
book was sold in target.
So while you were like grabbing
all your toilet and beans,
you could pick up this pretty
book with flowers on it.
Yeah, and so in this really messed up way,
it was the perfect time
for this book to come out.
And I think I probably reached
out much broader audience
than I otherwise would have.
And I don't, I'm not happy that,
you know who was your (indistinct).
Like, I don't, I'm not
like the kind of person
who needs to look for silver
linings and everything.
I just think both things are true.
Like it was sad that it happened in a way
that I didn't expect and
it, amazing and wonderful.
And I've been able to
connect with so many people
and hopefully be helpful in a time
where I would really want to be helpful.
Like this is the time
to serve your community.
If not now then when you know?
- Yeah, it's so important.
So, the investment I
think is so worthwhile
for so many people.
And even you know as you're
talking through this,
I'm just curious to you about,
how you even got yourself to that place
of putting a book together,
especially with your
initial kind of reaction
to the whole self-care mode.
And that's again to a place of,
I mean, the way you're talking now
really wanting to invest
in people and the community
and kind of empower people,
like how did that transition happen?
- Yeah, so I guess for me, I
never set out to write a book,
like that was not on my mind.
I set out to save my life.
The origins of the book were,
I grew up in a neglectful,
psychologically abusive household
where things came to die.
You know my first memory is
of a family of deer dying
in our lap pool
and me seeing the water a
lot, carcasses on a blue tarp.
I was like probably five
and it was just an
unsafe place to grow up,
chaos, constant screaming from my parents.
And I didn't have any role models of like,
no one was taking care of me.
They weren't taking care of them.
There was just no thoughts
that maybe it would be important
to take care of yourself.
So I really used external achievement
as a way to get myself out of that house.
You know I was the teacher's
pet, doing the extra credit,
extra curricular literary, magazine, APs,
award, award, award, you
know, hustle, hustle, hustle.
This will save me, like work will save me.
And in a funny way it kinda did
because it got me to Brown.
You know which was like
a fancy Ivy League school
that put like a nice stamp on me,
which helped me get my
first entry-level job
at Comedy Central.
And I just kept hustling
and working and going
'cause that's all I knew how to do.
But in the inside, I
was utterly imploding.
I was living in a permanent panic attack
where my jaw would clench down so hard
that like I understood
what the term gnashing of teeth meant.
Like it created like a chronic migraine,
which then I had to take
other medication for
and then I would self-medicate
with weed and booze and boys
and just trying to distract
because I had no interior life.
Like there was no there, there,
I didn't know who I was, I was lost.
And I might've kept just going that way
had I not hit rock bottom
on my 25th birthday
when I drunk dialed my therapist
and threatened to hurt myself.
And for me that morning,
the morning after when I
was listening to voicemails
from her and kind of piecing together,
oh my God, I'm in trouble, like
I could have killed myself.
Like my therapist who
was like a very rational,
calm, vaguely European woman
who always just had on a
scarf and a little cup of tea,
like she was worried
and that was the first time I got worried.
So that morning I just decided,
okay, I don't have parents.
I don't have like a wise mentor to go to
but I do have my hustle.
Like I do have this thing in me
that's always trying to achieve.
So what if I made a Google Doc
of how to repair it myself?
Like what if I tried and I
just wrote in the Google Doc,
it started with just questions
I had like, what are values?
What are principles?
What are vegetables?
Like genuinely what vegetables
should I be eating right now?
What is quinoa?
Is that a vegetable?
The answer is no.
Like so it was, it's an ancient grain.
So it was really even that basic,
like do I need to be drinking water?
Yes, like would making
my bed be a good idea?
Hell yes, like very basic things like that
but then much bigger
things like confronting
why am I in the same romantic relationship
over and over and over again?
And why am I so comfortable
when other people make
me feel uncomfortable
or make me feel small?
Like why is that so familiar?
And so I did this for five years
and at the end of five years,
I had a 600 page Google Document.
I felt like a completely different person.
I felt stable.
You know I wasn't self-medicating,
I wasn't running away from
my life, I was living it.
And that's when I decided
I have an offering,
I have something to
share with other people.
I wish someone had shared
their journey with me
that would have been helpful.
And as I wrote that book
and I realized, oh, I
have all these tricks too.
'Cause just from my Google
Doc I would have a list,
like I started listing
what makes me feel good.
Like I really started noticing
this is what makes me feel good
and these are the questions
that helped me in my journal.
And this is how exercising
affects my body and my brain.
So I just had all of these lists
that I thought might be
helpful to somebody else.
And so they just were, became
a part of the stories to me.
And once I realized it was useful,
then I kind of got over my initial,
uh, I don't wanna be a self-help writer.
'Cause I'm like, wait, why?
Every author who's ever lived,
if their book made you feel less alone
was a self-help author in some way,
they reached out your
hand and said you belong
and they do it in their own way.
And I just wanted to be more explicit
because I would have appreciated
if someone had been more explicit with me.
So that's sort of,
I just wanted to be of use and of service.
So that's how I got over
the sort of my initial
distain of self-help.
- Right, well, I appreciate you taking us,
yeah, through that journey.
I mean, there's so much there too.
I'm just impressed by the
level of introspection
that you had too,
to be able to, and diligence
to go through that process.
So I think a lot of us
will have just gotten tired
of that process to be completely honest.
And then like, I can't do this anymore.
It's the fact that you're
able to kind of keep going,
I mean, it sounds like you were seeing,
would you say you were seeing
things change along the way
or was it a specific moment?
- Oh, every step was like a
brand new life was being born.
And I really wanna be clear
that I wasn't pumped to do this.
I wasn't like, yay, this is
gonna be so fun and not hard.
I mean, there were many
times where I was just like,
why do I have to work so hard at this?
Like why do I, everybody else,
like this is when I get really self-pity,
which I definitely have in me.
I'm like, why is everybody else
just get to live their life?
And like here I am with
the stupid Google Document,
like chatting how many drinks
of alcohol work for me.
Like why am I even doing this?
And why I was even doing this
was I wanted to be healthy.
You know at the bottom of everything,
it was like, well, it
was for my own health.
And so I just kept going.
And I think the thing
I was born with that,
if you believe in God or
the universe or whatever,
is I was born with a soul
that wanted to be healthy
and I don't really have to
feed it much more than that.
Like it just wants to be healthy.
It just wants to be free.
And so when I get tired of this stuff,
I just lean back on the truth of me,
which is I wanna be
liberated, I wanna be healthy
and let that energy carry me.
- Yeah, well, that's so thoughtful.
- Was that to (indistinct),
did I just go way over?
- That was definitely good.
And I appreciate you talking
about the struggle too.
'Cause I feel like that's half of it,
like it doesn't help us when
we only hear about the victory
on the other side.
But to know that, like you're
like this is not exciting,
it's painful but I've got to do it.
And like you had this
internal God-given drive
to just keep going.
- I mean, the whole
preface to my second book
which I'm working on right now,
and it will be way cut down
but is a, greatest hits of my complaints
about why do I have to do this?
It's never been like, ouh,
this is easy and so fun,
like if you're listening to this.
You know like, man, it's a struggle
to face my life as it
really is and heal myself,
you are correct.
It is a struggle and it is
really hard and you can bear it
because you already are.
Whatever you've been through
is already dealing with you.
So it's just an opportunity
that you can choose your reaction.
It's just like a slight shift,
like it's a different kind of suffering.
It's a suffering I enjoy more.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
I mean, in some ways as you're talking to,
it seems like there's parallels too
to the way that you approached
your work before that too.
'Cause I mean, you basically
stayed on your grind.
You made sure you knew what
you had to do, you did it.
But with this it's the same type of thing
and we don't always think about that way
when we're dealing with
emotional challenges.
Sometimes it's easy to just feel like,
oh, I wish this was just fixed.
Even though we know like
deep down I think we know
we still got to put in that work
but just doesn't come naturally.
- You're exactly right.
It's you know when we have a
work project and we're like,
I need to, when we think about
it rationally, like goal,
like here's the small goal than this
and I'll lead to this and
that's how I'll achieve this.
But then take a thing like generosity,
like I wanna be more generous.
We just are like, and magically
that will happen somehow
or I wanna have a better
relationship with my mom
and magically, like in
time, we'll do that.
No, it's not time, it's work.
Just like every other
thing in life, it's work,
we can all do work so
we can all achieve this
and that is the message of my book is.
There is no special reason
that I should have been
able to repair it myself.
I'm special in certain ways,
that's not how I'm special.
It was just sticking to doing work
and having a little
faith that I was worth it
and that I could do it.
- Yeah, I think that's so good
and you're reaping the benefits
and then helping so many
people at the same time.
Again, it was such a process,
it sounds like to get there.
'Cause I even heard you talk about
ways that you felt like
you're really good at work
but bad at life.
You had to really come to terms with that.
And again, it goes back to that whole idea
of just being honest with ourselves
and be like, okay, this
aspect of life needs work
and I can't just leave it
and expect it to all
of a sudden fix itself.
- It's honesty and self-awareness.
Those are the keys to having a life
that doesn't feel like
it's happening to you.
It's, and it takes a
lot to look at yourself
and all of your flaws and say like,
well, this just is really me.
But what I've found is, in
getting back to acceptance,
just accepting that
gives me so many options.
I have options now to change if I want to
and there are some things
about me I don't wanna change,
like I'm an extremely trusting person
often to my own detriment.
I don't want to change that about me.
Like I like that,
I like that 'cause it opens
me up to a lot of possibility
and it's painful
because that's living with
your heart on your shoulders,
just can be a little painful.
And I can handle that,
well, you know what,
I'm doing it currently.
So I do think it's
that honest accounting
of where we really are
and being self-aware enough to know,
and I can change this with some work.
Like it's not just gonna
magically hit one day.
- Yeah, I think that's so well said.
I'm also curious 'cause
there's so many (indistinct)
I feel like resonate with a lot of people,
just how people have
responded to the book itself.
'Cause one of the pieces
that I feel like you've
highlighted really well
is just how easy it is to be
dismissive of any challenges.
And just to think, well,
so-and-so has it worse than me,
which could be true.
It's often true and kind
of look back at ourselves
and be like, oh, I
shouldn't be struggling.
'Cause I mean, I've seen that
a lot during the pandemic.
Like any specific
individual that I talked to,
whatever their circumstances,
they feel bad that they're struggling
because they can pick out
someone else who's doing worse
and they feel like why, I
shouldn't be struggling.
They are struggling, so
they can't get as much done
or they're struggling in certain areas
and they feel anxious and depressed
'cause they can't move to that.
Maybe not clinical depression per se,
but that loophole definitely
starts to kick in pretty early.
So I'm curious if you had people
talked with you about that
as they've been reading
through your books?
Are there ways that
you've tried to even move
past that kind of
reaction in your own life?
- Yeah, I mean, absolutely.
And you're hitting on
I think one of the biggest
things that I've found.
'Cause for so long I didn't wanna heal
because I didn't have it that bad.
I should be better, and I'm
doing massive air quotes.
And what I kind of realized
was that was not
beneficial for other people
who perhaps were suffering more from me,
like me minimizing my
experience it didn't help them.
And it certainly wasn't helping me,
so just who in the world
was I dismissing myself for?
And once I kind of like
saw that kind of clearly,
I realized this isn't helpful,
this isn't productive,
I gotta reframe this.
And the writer Lori Gottlieb,
who wrote, Maybe You
Should Talk to Someone.
And she's one of my absolute favorite
writers, thinkers, everything.
She talks about in her book
this theory of, there's
no hierarchy of pain.
There really isn't,
nobody's pain is any more
valid than anyone else's
because it's real.
Like you're talking about your friends
or someone who they're
denying their own suffering
because it's not a worst case scenario.
That doesn't mean it isn't
still painful for them
and that isn't their absolute reality.
And so again, if we deny what is real
then we can't deal with anything.
I often ask myself, what would
the wisest version of me,
how would the wisest version
of me handled this situation?
I call it future Tara.
Like how would future Tara handle this?
'Cause I don't have all this wisdom now,
like in the future maybe,
so like how would she deal with this?
And often it's, I wouldn't dismiss myself
or wouldn't call myself stupid and silly.
I wouldn't demean myself.
I would look at the actual circumstances
and try to help myself,
try to resource myself
and deal with them so that
they did not deal with me.
And so readers have
really picked up on this
and they've talked a
lot about feeling like,
they didn't have, the quote
unquote, worst childhood ever.
And that because it wasn't
on the news level bad,
they never dealt with it.
But now they see that
it's dealing with them
and that they have to
go back and do some work
and confront these things
that they actually are
confronting every single day.
So yeah, I've really seen
that people kind of being,
pausing and denying
their actual experience.
- Yeah, and I think that's great
to just to get people to realize that
because that's half, sounded
like GI Joe, half the battle
but I'm also over age.
- No, it isn't, it's also like,
we're still having trouble with it.
Like it's also condescending
to think of other people
as much, much worse.
Like who are you even,
like the whole thing is
so backwards and weird
that it's like better if you can just,
however you need to move off of it.
Just like let's just
move off of that idea.
- Yeah, and even the way that you're,
I mean, the way that you're
inspiring so many people to,
I mean, another topic
that we talk about a lot
and I know we talked about
this offline before too.
Just that whole balance between
helping yourself versus
helping other people
and just the danger of
ignoring our own challenges
and trying to help other people.
I mean, that's also come
up in other podcasts before
with other psychologists
that have come on,
you know as us being healers,
the healers can't help heal
if they're not going
through that healing too.
So how do you balance
that in your own life?
I mean, with this explosion of support
that you're giving while
you still have your own life
to kind of walk through too?
- It's been an unexpected
little bit of an adjustment
because I don't, 'cause
I'm still in process.
And the thing about my book and my writing
is like I don't know all the answers.
I'm not an expert.
Like I don't have a single degree
in any of the things I'm talking about.
What I am is a little sponge.
Like I just sponge in
everything that I can learn
and then I try to apply it in a real way
that I think is relatable to other people
'cause I can really break it down.
So that's what I am.
I'm not the one who did the research,
I'm not the one who like has
your degree and is at Yale.
So I've really had to
kind of say to myself is,
and I don't know,
I'm trying to still
really figure it out is,
how can I be the most helpful?
I know what feels the best,
the best feelings I have are
when I'm writing the book.
Like when I'm really,
really trying to be honest
and the work connects with people.
I like when I speak to a bigger crowd,
that feels really good.
I like when I talk
one-on-one with somebody
if I just like meet them,
but constantly being in my DMs
or replying to every single email,
even though these messages
are utterly beautiful
and even though people
are gracing me with the
hardest moments of their lives,
if I do every single one
I can't write, I can't go
speak to a bigger group.
So I myself, because I'm
so, I crave connection,
given that I had none growing
up and I felt so alone.
Like one of my driving forces
is a feeling of connection.
And so I'm having to figure
out how do I connect?
How do I help in a way that
I am not completely depleted
and so that I can continue the work?
So it's really like an open question.
I don't know the answer,
gen I have no idea.
I'm just still trying to kind
of figure out for myself.
- It's a process and a journey.
I mean, if I'm being completely honest
I feel like I'm on that
journey in some ways too.
- And you must be in particular,
'cause we talked a little bit offline too
about how even in your profession,
like professionally your job is to help.
But then does it become
everyone coming to you
to kind of like fix or explain
to them what's going on.
And does that feel like such a response?
Like I could imagine that
feeling both like an honor,
you know this person's coming to me
but also wait, wait, wait,
like I need to maintain some boundaries.
- Yeah, so I think even for me
it's something I'm still walking through
and figuring out on a day-to-day basis.
Because like you said,
each of those conversations
can be so personal
and touching and
empowering in a sense too.
But then knowing how
much to engage in those
versus there's a lot
of research that we do,
there's this podcast obviously.
And so you know I still
have to eat and sleep
but just like how do you balance that
and not spread yourself so thin
that you become completely
ineffective for everyone?
So I appreciate the
way you're sharing that
and I'd say a lot of ways.
Yeah, I wouldn't say I've
arrived in that place
but some of it is just having
folks who can look into,
and kind of watch and say,
okay, I think you're getting
a little bit spread thin here,
is there anything to go back on?
- That's interesting,
can I ask you a question?
- Yeah, flip the script.
- Yeah, I gotta flip the
script for the second.
Who in your life asks you that question
like, "Hey, are you spread too thin?"
- Yeah, so I'd say some of it
is just like going to
people in faith communities.
So a pastor that I'm pretty close with
who has basically been in this journey.
We did an event together back in 2019
called God's mental health
and wellness in New York City.
So having him just kind
of interject and check in
and see how things are
going, opportunities
and just sometimes not even
having to ask the question
but knowing me well enough
to be able to kind of sense
and ask questions that
will get me to that place.
And in sometimes to be honest it's just,
even just acquaintances
or, not even acquaintances
but colleagues that I know really well,
when we sit down and talk about
all the different initiatives
that are going on in the research,
I'm also doing a lot of work
around diversity, equity
and inclusion, anti-racism,
there's a podcast, there's
informal mentoring.
So people were asking are you taking,
I mean, someone asked me last week,
are you taking enough time for yourself?
Like are you actually
setting back?
- What was your answer?
- I said it's a strategic process.
Some days are better than the others.
And then you know you're balancing,
I mean, I'm married, I have kids as well.
So you put all that in the mix.
So to be honest, like to me,
when someone asks that
kind of point of question,
it's challenging, frustrating
and refreshing all the time.
Because that's really when
I have the opportunity
to check myself and say,
"Well, is this actually true?"
Or am I getting to a point
where this is just not sustainable, so?
- Well, it's so important
to have people in your life
who like truly know you in that
way to even ask the question
and that they're not afraid
to ask like, is this too much?
I often silence those people.
You know, I have a couple of
people in my life were like,
you're doing what now and
what now and what now,
is that too much?
I'm Like, I can handle it,
like don't put me down.
But when I can be not
defensive and not a jerk
and hear the question,
it's always, yeah, you're
doing way too much.
Like you need to find a
middle gear and I accept that,
except I'm, this is a
place where I'm processing
and trying to figure out
like, what's my middle gear.
- Well, I appreciate you asking honestly
and asking the question too.
- Yeah.
- I was gonna get there
but you may be pulled out
even more than that I probably would've
so you're very skilled in that sense.
- My trick.
- Yeah, I think it's so
important in a lot of ways
'cause it's so easy for us to just,
in several ways just spread
too thin and not be about,
almost like we're being
about too much at once.
And I've talked to some people
just in terms of even just
professionally people are saying,
well, you know you're gonna
have to say no sometimes
and you're gonna feel guilty about that
but you actually just kind
of have to deal with it
and ride the guilt
and just think about
where your priorities are.
So I think that's another place that,
it takes some time to get there.
- And I think the pandemic
has kind of hastened the idea
that we need to stick to our priorities.
You know I think a lot of
people what they saw is,
you know maybe going to like 50 weddings
and constantly out of town
and work, work, work, work,
wasn't making me happy and was
it like weird own priority?
And isn't actually in line with
what my real priorities are,
or for a lot of people
it was the first time they ask themselves
what are my priorities?
What are they even?
And I really hope that
coming out of the pandemic,
we can retain some sense of
our priorities of who we are
and how we want to carry
ourselves in the world
and then follow through.
So, I remember before the pandemic
like always being on a work trip,
complaining to my friends
about how much I had to travel.
And now I look back and like, what a jerk?
Like wasn't even looking at it
as the gratitude for a while,
I get to go to cool places,
was so jaded that I'm like complaining
and who did that benefit?
Because I wasn't enjoying it.
And the people I was flying to
their bachelorette into loom
or whatever the detail was,
you know people know when
you don't wanna be somewhere.
It's not like you're fooling everybody.
Like we're all smart, like we know.
The woman who you're like
have grudgingly agreed
to go to lunch with,
like as you check your watch,
she doesn't feel like seen.
So even with things like,
people are starting to ask
can you go to coffee again?
'Cause you know, I'm vaccinated,
you know other afraid vaccinated people.
And I'm like, do I really
wanna go to coffee?
'Cause I don't think I do, so now what?
I'm really like, I'm just in real time,
stating my issues right now.
- So in some ways it sounds
like you're reprioritizing too.
And I think a lot of
people have done that,
especially the way you
talked about your trips too.
- Yeah, definitely.
- I have to do this after this
and I know you've talked
about that before too,
shifting to I get to do this.
I mean, I think for even me personally,
a lot of us those trips
now feel like a luxury
like, oh, if I were
gonna do that right now,
just a whole different
perspective on things.
- I'm kind of scared to be
honest, I haven't flown yet.
I don't have any real
like big trips planned
and I used to travel all of
the time and I love traveling.
And now I'm just kind of scared,
I'm scared of my life
getting out of control.
I don't want to ever go back to the place
where I wasn't prioritizing
the things that really mattered to me.
And the pandemic, I was
fortunate to be in a situation
where I got to focus on the
things that mattered to me.
And it's almost like a drug
addict and like I'm seeing like,
and now I'm in the room again
with all the things that used
to get me high or whatever.
And then for me it's
like travel, distraction,
constant plans, planning,
doing, that's my drug of choice.
And so I'm a little afraid,
like I'm actually a little afraid.
- Yeah, how are you going to re-engage?
Do you have, between that
and just like your daily self-care,
like how do you plan
to step into the world
or is that still a process
you're figuring out?
- I think it's say, no,
more, like doing a lot less,
doing the things I actually
want to do and baby stepping.
I'm gonna take my first trip
with two of my best friends.
We're gonna do it one overnight,
one night overnight by
the beach this weekend.
You know that's feels like a good,
start small, start incrementally,
remember the big picture which is,
I don't wanna over plan again.
I don't need to distract
myself from my life,
not everything has to be an achievement.
And even working it into
my everyday schedule
so that I have more breaks,
you know even when I'm writing
that I write by timing myself.
So I have like a timer
and when the timer goes off
after an hour, I'm free.
So then I get up, I dance to one song,
then I sit back down, it's my second hour
but it's that little break,
you know that little time
to enjoy and not to produce
and not make anything.
So I'm trying to, I'm really
trying to bake into my life
the habits of what my
actual priorities are
as opposed to just get back
into the swing of things
as soon as I possibly can.
- Yeah, I appreciate you kind
of walking us through that
in real time.
And I think that's so,
I mean, I love the just
the incremental steps,
it's just kind of re-engaging.
I mean, in a lot of ways,
like everything is talking
about is self-care too.
And thinking ahead in some ways
when you're talking about future Tara,
it's like you're anticipating
what you'll learn
and trying to teach that to yourself now.
So you can to continue to move forward
which I think is great.
- I think it's really to give future Tara
the resources she needs
'cause I'm not smart enough.
I don't know like what she's gonna learn,
I'm not a fortune teller
but like I can fill out what resources
that person I might want to be needs
and I can give her that.
I can make choices today you know,
and that is self-care
because that's everything.
That's like, so I can go for a run,
I don't know ultimately,
am I gonna lose a little weight, am I not?
I don't know.
But I can go on this
run, that's how I eat,
what's this all gonna mean in the future?
I don't know.
But I can eat more fruits and vegetables,
like I definitely can do that.
And it's even like very practical things
like around fertility,
like I just went through
an egg retrieval process,
which was a whole other topic.
But I definitely did that for
the future version of myself
to have more options.
So I think one really
good self-care tip is,
thinking about what will
you want to be possible
for yourself in the future?
And what resources can you give
that version of yourself today?
'Cause then you benefit
from that in the present
and you benefit from that in the future.
- Yeah, that's so good.
I really love that perspective
and just the way that
you're carrying that out
on a daily basis in a lot of ways.
And I mean, the way you're
sharing that with us too
so definitely towards that top piece.
And I know I'm curious just even about,
and you've talked about this
already, but just legacy.
Like what are you trying?
I know that's a,
sometimes we don't think
about that at a younger age
but I think that you know,
just with the type of work
you're doing, I'm just curious
if that's something that
you've thought through
and what you're trying to
leave for others in the sense?
- Yeah, I oddly try to
think about it every day
and I don't use the word legacy
but I do think about when
I'm dead and it's my funeral,
what do I want said about me?
Like what's the impact
I wanted to have on other people's lives?
And am I living in accordance with that?
And I think the most important thing
is I want to be remembered as
somebody who saw other people,
who made other people
feel like they belonged,
who made other people feel less lonely
and who really thought
and herald other people.
And that would be a life well lived
as if I was a thoughtful passenger here.
So it's definitely,
that's like the big one.
And then the second
thing I think about is,
I want to show gratitude
for the fact that I ever got
to live by enjoying this time
and not making it like a constant struggle
and a crisis to endure
but really luxuriating in
the details of a sunny day
in Los Angeles,
where I got to take a run
and feel sweat on my body.
And I got to talk to you Dr. Addy
and that is actually magical.
Like that's lucky, that's cool.
My active gratitude is
to actually enjoy it
and not just let it wash over me,
not let my life just like rush away.
So I really do think about it quite often
and I encourage other
people to really think about
what do you want said about you?
You know like it's morbid
but it's also very freeing
because you then realize,
oh, I have a lot of say in that.
It's not some magic, again,
it's not some magical mystery,
it's you gotta do the work.
- Yeah, wow, that's so good.
I mean, thriving in a sense
as you're talking about
not just being, but really
thriving (indistinct).
You know having that impact and
caring for those around you,
I get the sense just in talking to you
and from everything you've
talked about with your book,
I feel like you're definitely
fulfilling that purpose
in a lot of ways, in a
lot of people's lives.
So definitely appreciate you.
Do you wanna say about the new book at all
or is that premature?
Do you wanna---
- Yeah, it's a little early
but I'm very excited too that
I get to write another book.
That's very exciting to me.
- Yeah, well said.
Well, definitely appreciate
you taking the time
to share your journey with us.
I'm impressed that you pulled
some of that out of me too,
I think that was more of that.
But you had just so much here
and I just really appreciate the realness
and you talking through
how you got to this point,
what you're kinda trying to do
to go through on a daily basis.
And I think there's so many lessons
that all of us can learn
just in walking through
this life with you,
vicariously through your book,
through these engagements
and things like that.
So definitely appreciate you sharing,
taking time to jump on
the Addy Hour today.
- Yeah, well, thank you for having me
and thank you for such a
thoughtful conversation
and for sharing yourself.
Because I know that's
not easy to really share
and I really appreciate that you did.
- Yeah, I appreciate
you asking the question.
Alright, thanks so much Tara.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)